addiction trauma body image issues and
divorce to be more will be laying it all
out in an upcoming memoir titled inside
out the tell-all is scheduled for
release on September 24 et has learned
to me will go behind the headlines of
her splits to both Bruce Willis and
Ashton Kutcher the publisher promises
readers will be quote surprised and
moved early in my career I was spiraling
down a path of real self-destruction
this book won't be the first time Moore
has been honest about her past
last October while accepting an award
from the women's recovery center the me
implied her struggles with substance
abuse led to an intervention they
presented me with an opportunity to mate
him okay we entertained an ambulance
here in 2012 Demi made headlines when
EMTs rushed to her home after a
suspected drug overdose this bright
light has been turned on into the
darkness laughter i sat down exclusively
with the star who is normally very
private to be talked about all the
trailblazing moments throughout her
career Vanity Fair
posing on the cover when you were
pregnant why shouldn't a woman be
celebrated when she's in the most one of
the most beautiful phases of her life
twenty years ago you were the
highest-paid actress for a movie role
usually the the question is you know why
not through my actions and how I live of
course you want to be like here making a
positive impact
[Music]
[Applause]